¿Dentro de 100 años?
¿Doscientos años?
Y estos son tres cambios muy profundos
que no son cosas del futuro.
Son cosas que hoy damos por sentado.
Por eso el código de vida resulta ser un superpoder.
Resulta ser un superpoder increíble para cambiar virus,
para cambiar plantas, animales,
quizá incluso para evolucionar nosotros mismos.
Es algo en lo que Steve Gullans y yo hemos estado pensando durante un tiempo.
Asumamos algunos riesgos.
Al igual que toda tecnología potente como la electricidad, el automóvil,
las computadoras, esto potencialmente podría usarse indebidamente.
Y eso asusta a mucha gente.
Y aplicando estas tecnologías,
podemos incluso transformar humanos en quimeras.
¿Recuerdan el mito griego en el que se mezclan animales?
Bueno, algunos de estos tratamientos
en realidad terminan cambiando el grupo sanguíneo.
O pondrán células masculinas en un cuerpo femenino o viceversa,
algo que suena absolutamente horrible
hasta que uno se da cuenta de que la razón para hacer eso
es sustituir la médula ósea durante los tratamientos de cáncer.
Así que recibir médula ósea de otra persona,
puede cambiar algunos aspectos fundamentales de uno mismo,
pero también le salva la vida.
Y mientras lo piensan,
esto es algo que pasó hace 20 años.
Esta es Emma Ott,
recientemente admitida en la universidad,
donde estudia contabilidad.
Practica dos deportes y se gradúa como mejor alumna.
Y eso no es particularmente extraordinario,
salvo que es el primer ser humano nacido de tres padres.
¿Por qué?
Porque ella tenía una enfermedad mitocondrial letal
que podría haber heredado.
Cuando intercambiamos el ADN de una tercera persona
y lo añadimos allí,
salvamos la vida de la gente.
Pero también se realiza ingeniería de la línea germinal,
lo que significa que sus hijos, si tendrá hijos, estarán a salvo
y no pasarán por esto.
Sus hijos estarán a salvo,
y sus nietos estarán a salvo,
y se mantendrá esta herencia.
Eso pone nerviosa a la gente.
Hace 20 años, diversas autoridades dijeron:
¿Por qué no estudiamos esto un tiempo?
Hay riesgos al hacer cosas, y hay riesgos al no hacer cosas,
porque hay un par de docenas de personas que se salvaron con esta tecnología
y lo hemos estado pensando durante los siguientes 20 años.
Y mientras lo pensamos,
nos tomamos el tiempo para decir: "Quizá deberíamos hacer estudios más largos,
quizá deberíamos hacer esto, y aquello",
hay consecuencias por actuar, y las hay por no actuar.
Como curar enfermedades letales...
lo que, por cierto, es totalmente antinatural.
Era normal y natural que los humanos fueran diezmados
por epidemias masivas de polio, de viruela, tuberculosis.
Cuando vacunamos personas, estamos poniendo cosas no naturales
en sus cuerpos
porque pensamos que el beneficio es mayor que el riesgo.
Gracias a que construimos plantas y animales no naturales,
podemos alimentar a unas 7000 millones de personas.
Podemos crear nuevas formas de vida.
Y conforme creamos nuevas formas de vida,
de nuevo, suena muy aterrador y terriblemente molesto,
hasta que advertimos que esas formas de vida viven en la mesa del comedor.
Esas flores que tienen en la mesa del comedor
no tienen mucho de naturales,
porque las han criado para que tengan ese color,
ese tamaño, para que duren una semana.
Por lo general no regalamos flores silvestres a los seres queridos
porque no duran mucho tiempo.
Todo eso trastoca las ideas de Darwin por completo.
Vean, durante 4000 millones de años,
lo que vivía y moría en este planeta dependía de dos principios:
la selección natural y las mutaciones aleatorias.
Por eso lo que vivía y moría, lo que estaba estructurado,
ahora ha cambiado por completo.
Y nosotros creamos
este sistema evolutivo completamente en paralelo
en el que practicamos selección no natural y mutaciones no aleatorias.
Explicaré ambas cosas.
Esto es selección natural.
Esto es selección no natural.
(Risas)
Ocurre que empezamos
a criar lobos hace miles de años
en Asia central para convertirlos en perros.
Luego empezamos a convertirlos en perros grandes y en perros chicos.
Pero si tomamos uno de los chihuahuas
que vemos en los bolsos Hermès en la Quinta Avenida
y lo soltamos en la llanura africana
podemos observar qué es la selección natural.
(Risas)
Pocas cosas en el planeta son menos naturales que un campo de maíz.
Nunca, bajo ninguna circunstancia, si caminamos por un bosque virgen
veremos la misma planta crecer en filas ordenadas
al mismo tiempo
y sin otras plantas viviendo allí.
Cuando cultivamos un campo de maíz,
seleccionamos lo que vive y lo que muere.
Y lo hacemos mediante selección no natural.
Ocurre lo mismo con un trigal o con un campo de arroz.
Sucede lo mismo con una ciudad y con una urbanización.
De hecho, la mitad de la superficie terrestre
tiene un diseño no natural
de modo que allí vive y muere lo que nosotros queremos,
y por eso no hay osos pardos
caminando por el centro de Manhattan.
¿Qué tal esta mutación aleatoria?
Bueno, esto es mutación aleatoria.
Este es Antonio Alfonseca.
También conocido como el Pulpo, su apodo.
Fue el lanzador revelación del año 2000.
Y tenía una mutación aleatoria que resultó en seis dedos en cada mano,
algo muy útil si uno es lanzador.
(Risas)
¿Qué tal la mutación no aleatoria?
Una mutación no aleatoria es la cerveza.
Es el vino. Es el yogur.
¿Cuántas veces caminando por el bosque
encontraron queso completamente natural?
¿O yogur natural?
Hemos diseñado estas cosas.
Ahora, lo interesante es que conocemos mejor el tema.
Encontramos una de las herramientas más poderosos de edición de genes,
la CRISPR, dentro del yogur.
Y cuando empezamos a diseñar células,
producimos ocho de los 10 primeros productos farmacéuticos,
incluyendo el utilizado para tratar la artritis,
que es el fármaco de mayor venta, Humira.
Este código de vida en realidad es un superpoder.
Realmente es una forma de programar cosas
y no hay nada que nos vaya a cambiar más que este código de vida.
Mientras piensan en el código de vida,
pensemos en cinco principios, para empezar,
y me encantaría que me sugieran más.
El principio número uno:
tenemos que asumir la responsabilidad por estas cosas.
La razón por la que tenemos que asumir la responsabilidad
es que estamos a cargo.
Estas no son mutaciones aleatorias.
Es lo que estamos haciendo, lo que estamos eligiendo.
No es algo que "ocurrió".
No ocurrió por azar.
No es producto de otra persona.
Nosotros lo diseñamos y sigue la regla de la empresa Pottery Barn:
lo rompes, lo pagas.
Principio número dos:
tenemos que reconocer y celebrar su diversidad.
Ha habido por lo menos 33 versiones de homínidos
que han caminado por el planeta.
La mayoría se extinguió, salvo nosotros.
Sin embargo, en el estado normal y natural del planeta
hay diferentes versiones de seres humanos caminando al mismo tiempo,
razón por la que la mayoría de nosotros tenemos algo de neandertales,
otros tenemos algo de denisovanos,
y algunos en Washington tienen mucho más de cada uno.
(Risas)
El principio número tres:
tenemos que respetar las decisiones de otras personas.
Algunas personas optan por no alterar nada,
otras por modificarlo todo.
Algunas personas optarán por alterar las plantas, pero no los animales,
otras por alterarse a sí mismos o simplemente evolucionar.
La diversidad no es algo malo,
porque a pesar de que pensamos que los seres humanos somos muy diversos,
estuvimos tan cerca de la extinción
que todos descendemos de una sola madre africana,
y la consecuencia de eso
es que hay más diversidad genética en 55 chimpancés africanos
que en 7000 millones de seres humanos.
Principio número cuatro:
deberíamos tomar una cuarta parte de la Tierra
y dejar a Darwin que haga lo suyo allí.
No tiene que ser contiguo o todo interconectado
y debería cubrir parte agua y parte tierra,
pero no deberíamos involucrarnos en cada decisión evolutiva del planeta.
Queremos que nuestro sistema evolutivo funcione
y el sistema evolutivo de Darwin también.
Y es muy importante tener estas dos cosas funcionando en paralelo
y no abrumar a la evolución.
(Aplausos)
Lo último que diré
es que esta es la aventura más emocionante emprendida por los humanos.
Este es el mayor superpoder que hemos tenido los seres humanos.
Sería un crimen no participar en esto
por tener miedo o querer evitar el tema.
Pueden opinar sobre su ética. Pueden participar en la política.
Pueden participar en el negocio.
Pueden participar solo pensando hacia dónde va la medicina, la industria,
y cómo controlaremos el mundo.
Sería un crimen para todos nosotros hacer caso omiso
a alguien que se presenta en una piscina y dice una frase, una sola frase;
sería un crimen si no escuchan aquella frase que es "código de vida".
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)